thanks to Dollar Shave Club for
sponsoring this video go to
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash fire
graphics you'll get a starter set for
just 5 dollars more on them in a bit the
year is 30 BC in the grand Egyptian
capital of Alexandria panic is sweeping
through the streets a mighty Roman fleet
is bearing down on the city bringing
fire and destruction in a half-finished
mausoleum Cleopatra and her lover Mark
Antony await the inevitable Antony's
stomach has already been sliced open and
now the great general is merely waiting
to die as Roman boots pound the streets
the wounded man orders one last cup of
wine then as his lover looks on he
offers her a final toast before
everything goes black the deaths of Mark
Antony and Cleopatra are some of the
most famous in all of history
breathlessly pored over by the ancients
turned into high tragedy by Shakespeare
the extinguishing of their love has been
fodder for countless adaptations but how
much the most of us know about Mark
Antony how did he come to be Cleopatra's
lover and how did the to wind up dying
in misery their dreams just so much ash
today by graphics is uncovering the
story of Mark Antony the man whose death
heralded the birth of an empire
one of the most interesting things about
mark ends in his early career is that it
basically reads like a greatest hits of
ancient history seriously
over the next six minutes you're gonna
watch him me Cleopatra Julius Caesar in
the future Emperor Augustus and see him
cross the Rubicon and help conquer Gaul
but Babs the most remarkable thing about
a guy who spent like his entire life at
the epicenter of history is just how
unremarkable
he seemed destined to be born on January
the 14th 83 BC Antony came from a family
that was rich but not respected his
father was a famously incompetent
general while his mother was a cousin of
Julius Caesar Caesar in 83 BC was just
some 17-year old boy who nobody knew
would one day become dictator it also
didn't help that Antony's early life was
remarkably dissolute as a teenager he
fell in love with a guy called curio who
was all about blowing Antony's money on
games and goals as a result
Anthony wound up 250 talents in debt
before he was just twenty years old some
of money that's equal to without five
million dollars today so Antony skipped
town heading to Greece to study
philosophy so you know those guys who
keep partying after college until it
just becomes embarrassing well that was
Mark Antony in Greece but his bohemian
ways did give him something more than an
endless hangover they left him with an
abiding love of Hellenistic culture
finally when Antony was 26 a Roman
general called all's Gabonese convinced
him to get his life in shape by joining
the war in Syria Antony agreed perhaps
hoping to find more places where he
could just get drunk what he found
instead was his vocation it turned out
Antony was great at war as a cavalry man
in Syria he distinguished himself again
and again likewise he did so in Egypt
where the Romans had been invited to
crush revolts against Ptolemy the 12th
it was while doing all of that revolt
crashing that Anthony was introduced to
one of Ptolemies teenaged daughters the
girl was only 14 but something about her
charms the young soldier hypnotizing him
the name of that teenage girl well you
guessed it that was Cleopatra but this
is just a quick cameo Manzoni didn't
immediately shack up with Clio but
instead he went off to fight in Gaul a
place roughly analogous to modern-day
France and Belgium there he served under
the second of the great figures who'd
shaped his life Julius Caesar by 54 BC
Caesar was no longer a
seventeen-year-old nobody but a great
general and along with Pompey and
another dude you don't need to bother
remembering a member of the first
triumvirate that called the shots in
Rome in short he was well on his path to
greatness which made Antony's arrival
perfect timing
under Caesar Antony continued to excel
at warring not only that he also
excelled at just being a soldier
drinking with his men eating alongside
them and earning himself a devoted
following among the rank-and-file by 50
BC and the end of the conquest of gold
Antony had proven himself so many times
that Caesar sent the 33 year-old back to
Rome to take the office of Tribune but
while being Tribune would have been
fitting cap for many Romans careers Mark
Antony was just getting started in
barely a year he was going to be ruling
the city itself
[Music]
when Anthony arrived Rome was in turmoil
Caesars fellow tram there Pompey was
trying to force the great general to
give up his army and there were frequent
clashes in the streets between their
supporters on to this political dumpster
fire Antony
poured a cascade of gasoline in the
Senate Antony hooks back up with his old
buddy curio now caesar's supporter ins
began goading Pompey things came to a
head when Antony suggested Pompey get
out of politics for the good of the
Republic leading to so many death
threats that Antony was forced to flee
all the way back to the frontiers of
Italy where Caesar was camped across a
river called the Rubicon so you probably
know the phrase crossing the Rubicon it
means to commit to a cause of action
from which there is no going back we
have this phrase because in 49 BC it was
forbidden for a commander like Caesar to
march his troops over the river and into
Italy but when Caesar heard Antony's
story he decided he had no choice so we
elevated Antony to his second-in-command
and then both literally and figuratively
crossed the Rubicon Mark Antony everyone
witnessed both major historic events and
the coining of everyday phrases the news
of Caesars crossing caused Pompey to
flee Rome this was great from the
perspective of Caesar being able to
waltz in and have himself declared
dictator but less good from the
perspective of Caesar as he now had to
track down his rival but before Caesar
gave chase II put the city under
Antony's control as supreme
administrator of Rome itself Antony was
almost comically useless Plutarch writes
that he was too lazy to pay attention to
running the city and well that's being
generous Antony was so negligent he
almost caused a revolution when Caesar
returned from fighting Pompey in Egypt
in 46 BC he was so stunned by what a
crappy job as number two was doing that
he kicked him out of the city
Franzen II this was a real double whammy
see Caesar hadn't returned from Egypt
alone but with Antony's old flame
Cleopatra in tow only Cleopatra was now
a client of Caesar which meant it put
her on the throne and she in turn had
been impregnated with his son Caesarion
when Antony was exiled to Gaul he wasn't
just stewing over his broken
relationship with Caesar but also Caesar
shacking up with
ruch sadly for anthony this
double-whammy was about to become triple
hit in 45 BC Caesar was forced to go
fight the sons of Pompey in Hispania ie
modern-day Spain but with Antony in
disgrace he needed a replacement by his
side the man II chose well that would be
his 18 year old great nephew Octavian
the future Emperor Augustus it was the
beginning of a rivalry between Antony
and Octavian that would shake the known
world
so now might be a good time to talk
about Octavian born in 63 BC Octavian
was 20 years younger than Mark Antony
like Antony had a family connection with
Caesar who was his grandma's brother but
Octavian never saw his famous great
uncle and may not have made much of an
impression if he had Octavian was weak
and sickly
in fact when 45 BC rolled around and
Cesar asked Octavian to accompany him to
Spain iya Octavian was too ill to go
bought Octavian lacked in muscles of
Steel he made up for with his iron will
the boy was ambitious and he knew the
path to greatness lay through Caesar as
soon as he was capable of moving he
dragged himself to asthenia to witness
the end of the war pleased that his weak
never had put himself in such danger
Caesar honored Octavian by letting him
ride home alongside him it was likely
during this journey that the fate of
Rome was transformed or gets that in a
minute while all of this was happening
Antony was still sitting in miserable
exile in Gaul and there he might have
stayed had Caesar not swung by to see
him on his way back to Rome it was now
almost two years since Caesar had
knocked up Antony's lady and kicked him
out so we like to imagine the greetings
were a bit awkward but the tea men soon
overcame their differences Antony was a
dyed-in-the-wool sees a lawyer list and
old Julius never could say no to a
sycophant
they are Stanton near to return with him
to the Eternal City and so there was
that in 45 BC three of the most
important men in history traveled
together across school but all was not
well back in Rome after the Rubicon
thing Caesars enemies were pretty sure
he meant to make himself into a king not
the
Antony helps matters in February 44 BC
Caesar was presiding over a religious
ceremony when Antony suddenly clambered
up towards him pulled out a laurel crown
and tried to declare his boss king of
Rome Caesar waives him off but the
damage had already been done
here was the dictators number two
literally trying to crown him King if
you were a Republican minded senator
back then well what would you have done
on March the 15th 44 BC the Ides of
March the Senate summoned Caesar as
Caesar was on his way Antony received a
warning that something was about to
happen and he rushed to tell his boss he
actually caught sight of him walking
into the Senate and tried to shout a
warning that the crowds were too heavy
and his voice was lost on the bustle of
Rome's streets Antony would never see as
mentor alive again Julius Caesar was
stabbed to death that day killed by his
own senate in the aftermath of the
assassination and zani fled Rome
convinced that he was next but Anthony
was wrong the plotters had never thought
to kill off Caesars loyalists Antony
Octavian they were all left alive when
Antony finally clicked that no one was
coming for him
he returned to Rome and reassumed his
position of consul the first thing he
did was open Caesars will curious to see
what the man had served so loyally had
left him what Caesar but left him was a
bit of a punch in the gut Caesars will
left nothing to Antony but it did leave
a huge fortune to Octavian as well as
posthumously adopting the boy turning
him into Caesars only Roman son suddenly
Antony was no longer the biggest man
left standing no longer the obvious heir
to the dictator there was now a powerful
rival Firenze Indian Romans there was
only one way that this rivalry could
ever end so guys as you can see this
video is a Piquet long and weakened dude
these super long videos thanks to the
kind support of our sponsors like Dollar
Shave Club Dollar Shave Club covers all
of your grooming needs shower or or care
deodorants and of course most
importantly shaving now obviously I
don't shave my beard except here here
but I do shave my head and that
experience has become well a whole lot
better since I joined Dollar Shave Club
and started using their super high
quality blades Dollar Shave Club sent me
their ultimate starter set which of
course has the razor it has the blades
but it also comes with these three
things you got a prep scrub for before
you've got the shave butter fan during
you've got the post shave do for
afterwards and my head tends to get a
little dry when I shave so this post
shaved you actually rehydrates it
afterwards keeps it nice and hydrated
which is always great you can visite
dollarshaveclub.com and get the ultimate
shave starter set for only just five
dollars and you can round out your
grooming routine by adding any of their
other high quality products after that
the restock box ships full-size products
at a regular price this is a great way
to support what we're doing here abaya
graphics and let's get back to the show
if the conspirators ever had considered
killing Antony they likely spent Caesars
funeral wishing they'd done it during
the procession Antony held Caesars
blood-stained toga high and gave a
thunderous speech denouncing those who'd
murdered him
the crowd was whipped into such a frenzy
that the conspirators were forced to
flee but Antony didn't really want
vengeance what he wanted was to take
over Caesars old job so after getting
the crowds riled up he began meeting
with the Senate trying to negotiate a
peaceful solution unfortunately he had
encounters on Octavian when Octavian
first heard of Caesars assassination
from Antony it also heard that the
dictator had willed all of his
possessions to the Roman people when he
found out that Caesar actually left
everything to him had figured out what
Antony's game was from that point on
Octavian did everything in his power to
hobble the old man his opening salvo was
to reveal to the riled-up mobs that
Antony was doing a deal with the Senate
Octavian whips them up into such a fury
that Anthony was forced to beat a
retreat from peace and declare himself
on the path of vengeance the our shot
was that's in January 43 BC Antony rode
out at the head of an army to Cisalpine
Gaul where the assassin Decimus Brutus
was lying low and no that's not the
famous Brutus just another assassin of
Caesar also called Brutus go figure
anyway long story short of the Senate
got annoyed his entity's unilateral
action and sent Octavian to stop him
instead the two rivals joined forces
destroyed Brutus as army and drove him
into the wilds a few days later a local
tribes and a box to Antony and insider
to lay Brutus as head shortly thereafter
Antony and Octavian met on a small
island under the eye of the mutually
trusted Lepidus the fight with bayless
Brutus had shown both men how powerful
they could be together although they
despised one another
neither was stupid they knew that alone
they might annihilate themselves but
together they could take out the whole
of Rome and with that the second
triumvirate was born forged between
Antony Octavian and their friends
Lepidus the second triumvirate would
rule Rome for 10 years they were
effectively invincible when they
returned to Rome the Senate basically
handed them the keys to the city when
the trial is announced the property of
mm Republicans was forfeited to funds
the coming war with the Rio Brutus and
his Co assassin Casius everyone just
look the other way but make no mistake
the second triumvirate was not an end in
and of itself but just a mere
stepping-stone all three parties wanted
to rule Rome solo all three knew that at
some point that have to kill their
rivals the only question was well when
in 42 BC Antony and Octavian finally
roadies to confront the assassins
leaving Lepidus in Rome the first battle
came in September and only resulted in a
draw a brilliant maneuver by Antony
captured Cassius's Kemp but an equally
brilliant act of stupidity by Octavian
led to Antony's camp simultaneously
falling to Casius but none of that's
actually mattered because Casius was
watching all of this from a hill with
poor visibility and failed to see his
own victory
so thinking it was all over he ordered a
slave to kill him which only left Marcus
Brutus of air to brute a Fame on October
the 23rd the is forced a final
battle this time there would be no draw
Brutus his army was crushed in the
aftermath the assassin climbs a nearby
hill pulled out his sword and drove it
into his own abdomen Brutus was dead the
war was over to celebrate Antony and
Octavian divided the Empire between
themselves the West
- Gaul going - Octavian while the east
went to Antony as Octavian headed back
to Rome Antony was left wondering what
to do he was now one of the two most
influential men on earth Lord of all
that lay east of the Adriatic so what's
a guy to do when he's given all that
power well he did what any guy would
want to do
Antony went off to impress a girl
[Music]
and so here we are after over half the
video we finally get to the part of
Anthony's life that everyone remembers
his relationship with Cleopatra that the
two became lovers at all is purely down
to luck while Anthony might have been
smitten by the Egyptian queen years ago
Cleopatra tended not to have
relationships out of love but out of
necessity
come 41 BC though what Cleopatra needed
was a guarantee from Rome that it would
continue to prop up her throne and what
better way to secure that guarantee than
by seducing a tram there
although Antony was the one who arranged
their meeting it was Cleopatra who
controlled it she arrived in Tarsus on a
boat with silver oars dressed as
Aphrodite girls waited on her every whim
and Greek music played for Anthony who'd
become obsessed with both Cleopatra and
Hellenistic culture in his youth this
must have been like watching all of his
late-night fantasies come true in fact
Antony was so smitten that he
accompanied the Queen back to Alexandria
there Windsor whether to formalized
their alliance but while clans Anu your
and to Petra may have started as an
alliance of convenience it soon grew
into something bigger that Windsor in
Alexandria the Queen and the Tryon there
were inseparable they started a group
called the Society of inimitable lovers
where they drank as much fine wine and
ate as much fancy food as they could
stomach they went out in the streets at
night together wearing disguises so no
one would recognize them by day they
hunted and slowly inevitably they began
to fall in love not that Antony had
taken his eyes off the prize though that
same wins earns and his family in Rome
tried to ferment rebellion against
Octavian likely on Antony's orders but
Octavian survived the rebellion and not
only eggs acted ruthless revenge but
took Antony's province of Gaul for
himself but this very nearly led to yet
another civil war but neither Antony nor
Octavian was strong enough yet but make
no mistake the blood between these two
was worse than it has ever been when the
second triumvirate term was renewed in
37 BC part of the deal was that Antony
would trade 120 ships for four of
Octavian's legions Antony sent the ships
off to Rome only to realize too late
that there would be no legions coming
Octavian had tricked him it Anthony
couldn't just march on Rome and destroy
his young rival just as Octavian
couldn't barge into Alexandria what
Antony needed was a PR triumph something
that would turn the whole of Rome into
his fanboys something like a glorious
victory in war so in 36 BC Antony
invaded Parthia the choice was
wonderfully symbolic in 53 BC parthia
had humiliated Rome Julius Caesar had
actually been preparing to attack right
before his assassination if Anthony
could finish what Caesar started there
would be no doubt about who was Julius
as real AB sadly though that was a big
if for the Romans invading Parthia was
kind of like modern European dictators
invading Russia it rarely worked out
Antony marched in expecting easy victory
and instead watched as brutal weather
killed over a quarter of his soldiers it
was forced to retreat without fighting a
single battle the bodged invasion was so
humiliating that Anthony's seriously
considered suicide in the end though he
simply slunk back to Alexandria to take
comfort in Cleopatra's arms there will
always be another chance
he just had to lick his wounds and try
again later
but Anthony was wrong there wouldn't be
another chance his fate had already been
sealed
if the invasion of Pavia was a PR
blunder then what Anthony did next was
like live streaming a video of himself
wearing swastikas while kicking puppies
back in Alexandria and soon he began to
dress more and more in Eastern fashion
he began acting not like a staid boring
Roman but like a hedonistic Greek and
this infuriated the staid and boring
Romans going native this wasn't done on
top of that Antony
started calling Cleopatra queen of
Queens warning sign that the Romans
might have to put up with a non Roman
Empress if Antony defeated Octavian but
Anthony's biggest mistake was probably
what he did with caesarian remember
caesarian he was the love child of
Julius Caesar and Cleopatra who got like
a 1 second introduction towards the
start of this incredibly crammed video
well Antony declares that not only was
caesarean King of Kings but this he was
also the true heir to Caesar - Octavian
this was basically a giant warning sign
that flashed you need to kill this dude
ASAP so Octavian prepared for his final
push first he removed Lepidus from the
triumvirate consolidating his power in
the western empire second he started a
fierce propaganda war painting Antony is
a weak General under the spell of a
wicked queen from Alexandria Antony
tried to fire back he started a rumor
that Caesar only adopted Octavian
because the boy had seduced the dictator
but Octavian was just better at this
kind of scheming when the second
triumvirate Stern expired he announced
he no longer wanted the title when
Antony hesitated about dissolving the
triumvirate Octavian was able to paint
him as a power-hungry tyrant it's all
rather ironic things finally crumbled in
32 BC Octavian stormed into the sacred
temple holding Antony's will and removed
it breaking every taboo in Roman society
but when he read it to the masses it
turned out Antony had done even worse in
his will Antony had left to the entire
eastern part of the Empire - Cleopatra
and her sons this was no longer just
going native
this was treason in a breezing season
the Senate declared war in Antony
grunting Octavian the power to fight his
rival down in Alexandria Antony realized
that time had come
taking 400 trips he appointed Cleopatra
his code general then sailed out an or
inspiring show of force sadly a show was
all it was
for whatever reason Antony was weary of
attacking room directly so he hung back
wintering his ships to the south in a
little bay with only a narrow entrance
in effect this Bay became his own noose
in spring 31 BC Octavian's ships managed
to blockade Antony inside the bay at the
same time a huge Overland army cut off
their escape for the next half year
Antony and his men were trapped in a
state of siege with too little water too
little food and way too much disease
finally realizing his entire army was on
the verge of deserting Antony forced to
battle on September the 2nd the Battle
of Actium is today a byword for
humiliating defeat
Octavian's ships pummeled Antony's
weakens Navy reducing it to so much
driftwood it was only a chance break in
Octavian's line that allowed Antony and
Cleopatra to personally escape in a
faster boat hightailing it back to Egypt
but there would be no escape now no
second chances Octavian was coming for
them and he wouldn't rest until Antony
was dead
[Music]
the end of Mark Antony's life is one of
the saddest examples of refusing to
accept a reality that you'll ever see
at first Antony and Cleopatra seemed to
have decided they could reason with
Octavian and they spent all winter
sending in envoy's when Octavian laughed
them off they began preparing a clearly
doomed defense of Alexandria yet neither
seems to have realized that the writing
was on the wall as they waited for
winter to pass Antony and Cleopatra
repeatedly got drunk and talked about
what they would do once they finally
defeated Octavian it was like hearing
two pigs discuss what they do once they
had taken over the slaughterhouse it's
depressing and amusing in equal measure
at long last in the final days of July
30 BC Octavian's fleet was spotted on
the horizon on August the 1st Antony
sent out the remnants of his navy to
meet them while he amassed an army on
land his plan was to give Octavian's
ships hell and then die gloriously in
battle a soldier to the ends but fate
had other plans as soon as they
approached Octavian strips Antony's Navy
raised the white flag of surrender on
lands his army saw what's happening
thought the ancient equivalents of to
hell with this dropped their weapons and
masts deserted the only one left was
Mark Antony standing impotently on the
hot Alexandrian shore watching death
approached humiliated the great general
tried to return to Cleopatra's palace
and see how on last time but Cleopatra
had sensed which way the winds were
blowing and had gone into hiding in an
unfinished mausoleum she made one of her
aides tell Antony that she'd already
committed suicide faced with the loss of
his empire his queen and certain death
Antony did the only thing he could do he
drew his dagger and he stabbed himself
in the stomach then he slid down onto
the floor bleeding and in agony but the
story isn't quite over yet
stomach wounds can take a long time to
kill you when Cleopatra heard what
Antony had done she changed her mind and
sent for him the dying man was dragged
to a mausoleum leaving a trail of blood
in his wake there he was propped up
facing his queen for the final time the
sight of her lover Cleopatra burst into
tears
Antony briefly tried to comfort her but
thought better of it with his last ounce
of strength he demanded that wine be
brought he took the cup toasted his
queen and
drank for the final time we don't know
mark Antony's real last words but
Shakespeare had him declare the
miserable change now at my end laments
nor sorrow at but please your thoughts
in feeding them with those my former
fortunes wherein I lived the greatest
prints of the world the noblest and do
now not basely die not cowardly put off
my helmet to my countrymen a roman by
roman valiantly vanquished now my spirit
is going I can no more
Mark Antony died on August the first 30
BC just hours before Octavian captured
Alexandria in the aftermath for 33 year
old had cesarean killed before annexing
Egypt into his empire although he
allowed Cleopatra to live he let her
know it would only be as a miserable
wretch without money or power rotting
away in some obscure Roman province
Cleopatra committed suicide on August
the 30th she was the last Pharaoh of
Egypt just three years later in 27 BC
Octavian assumes the name or Gustus
becoming the first Roman Emperor already
most had forgotten Mark Antony forgotten
the man who came so close to ruling the
Empire but not everyone in the two
thousand plus years since his death Mark
Antony has become a household name one
of the few ancients that almost everyone
remembers partly this is due to his
proximity to Caesar partly it's to do
with Shakespeare partly it's probably to
do with Richard Burton and Elizabeth
Taylor but there's more to it than
simply luck mark Antony's story is a
fascinating mix of so many things it's
an adventure story a story about how
power corrupts a love story for the ages
branching points for a million alternate
history tales in short it's a myth a
myth where God like kings and emperors
battle and rule and fall in love doing
everything on a scale far beyond normal
human life and yet it really happens the
life of Mark Antony may have been a
failure but it's also one that speaks to
us it's as poetic as any epic as
powerful as any Legend here in the fires
of love and war
the fate of the known world was decided
changing our planets history he may have
never been Emperor
he may have been played by Octavian but
Mark Antony was a historical Colossus a
guy who did more and loved more in his
lifetime than most of us could ever
dream of
in retelling his tale we can experience
just a shadow of those great feelings
too so I really hope you found that
video interesting if you did please do
subscribe to this channel please do like
this video please do check out our
fantastic sponsor Dollar Shave Club and
I'll see you next time